hi quick take today we are breaking down
the many symptoms of Kovan 19 i'm cream
amore and tokyo and welcome to our live
Q&A I'm joined today by Jason Gayle our
Bloomberg News health editor face and
Melbourne so Jason thanks for coming on
hey everybody how are you doing good how
are you not bad yeah
so today symptoms right I think many of
us are wondering what we can expect what
we should be looking out for when we
first heard about koban 19 pneumonia was
the big big worry to start out with but
now we keep hearing about other symptoms
and COBIT oh by the way by the way is a
big one that we've all been hearing
about that's been a super hot topic what
is that all about yes so we've as we've
now that four million cases at least
around the world we're seeing all kinds
of different manifestations of covert we
heard about things like diarrhea and
gastrointestinal upset then it was loss
of smell and taste and now we're hearing
about this covert oh so what we're
talking about here and you can see some
photographs are these blistering chill
blame like lesions purple bread they're
coming up on the toes sometimes they're
on the fingers sometimes other parts of
the foot and these are caused by tiny
blood vessel clots just beneath the skin
fortunately they're pretty benign but
they're nevertheless symbolic of someone
having the covert 19:00 infection so
something else we've heard in the past
couple of weeks
is that kovat can also cause strokes
especially in younger people so is that
related to kovat oh and other blood
clots yes indeed so that's on the other
spectrum of the severity scale other end
of this spectrum so strokes have been
appearing in younger people our New York
City Boston have reported cases
and in fact it's the the symptom that
brings people to hospital in some cases
it's still fairly rare overall I mean
some of these cities have had tens of
thousands of cases so the the
presentation of stroke is is fairly
unusual but in these younger people are
younger than 50 it is really pretty
striking and so patients have ended up
needing to have their clot removed
because it's lodged in a large vessel of
their brain threatening sort of major
neuro like neurological damage and that
has been a feature to of of code 19 or a
rare one though so talk us through it
for a lot of us who aren't medical
experts so what is causing the blood to
clot in the first place yeah so a few
viruses and infections can cause the
blood to coagulate and clot it's part of
the immune response to infection we're
seeing that happen quite a lot with
covert 19 that blood getting the blood
vessels actually getting damaged
particularly at that intersection of
where the the blood is oxygenated
through alveoli the other great like
sacs air sacs in the in the lung and
they're surrounded by these capillaries
and when the virus is attacking their
alveoli it's causing some disruption to
the butt lining of these capillaries and
that's starting off a cascade of
clotting and so little clumps of
platelets can end up moving around in
the bloodstream and then can sort of
lodge in peripheral places like the
fingers and the toes but then these
little clots can sort of snowball into
bigger clots and then they can move
around the bloodstream from like that
you might have heard of deep vein
thrombosis that's something that I can
occur when you're on a plane and sitting
down for 12 hours but we're seeing these
clots can occur in the deep veins of the
legs and move to the lungs and cause
what's called a pulmonary
embolism and so that's been a quite a
big problem in severely sick covered 19
patients of uuk pulmonary embolism so it
sounds like there are many many issues
associated with a blood clots of course
but is there anything doctors can do for
in it for Koba 1999 yeah absolutely so
doctors have now become a lot more alert
especially to this pulmonary embolism
problem because that's a clot that's in
the lung that can move across into the
arteries that supply the heart and when
there happens it can really cause a big
backup of blood and put put a lot of
pressure on the heart leading to cardiac
failure so doctors are now using a blood
test called the d-dimer blood test to
look for patients who might have clots
forming in their bloodstream and then
they can use anticoagulant medicines
like heparin to try to reduce the
formation of these clots and they can
also use clot-busting drugs to try to
dissolve the clots
so the good thing is that as doctors
have become a lot more aware of this
clotting problem they're able to use
preventative treatments and therapeutics
to actually address the problem because
we've seen clots are forming in the
bloodstream and and really cutting off
blood supply to organs throughout the
body like we've mentioned the lungs and
the brain and the toes but we've also
got seen the same phenomenon affecting
the liver and the kidneys and the bowel
and they've found clots in the prostate
and they've actually also seen which is
quite worrying in pregnant women clots
can conform the placenta and that can
actually reduce blood supply to the
fetus and that has been associated with
miscarriage and a reduction in birth
weight for the fetus so that's a concern
as well yeah that's terrible
I know some people have been saying
talking about these symptoms could kind
of be just trying to
can we talk a little bit about why maybe
learning about the symptoms and trying
to understand a little bit more about
kovat 19 symptoms can be important and
can be informative or for the average
Joe for everybody out there in the world
yeah absolutely I think all of these
unusual presentations atypical
presentations if you like can kind of
inform patients and doctors about what
to do what to do if they see someone
who's suddenly lost their sense of smell
and taste well could be a sign of the
corona virus infection and they should
get tested and if they're positive then
they need to self isolate so they can
stop spreading it to other people
same with covert OHS now that we know
that these odd lesions around the feet
and sometimes the fingers can be a sign
of of the blood clotting problem that's
associated with the disease again that
may lead to people recognizing that they
may have the corona virus infection and
to stop isolating in or if they do start
to get other symptoms seek care for it
in the hospital or by a health care
provider so all of these things are sort
of informing a better response to the
infection and ideally to prevent it from
spreading to other people
great yeah so before I asked you this
next question everybody who's watching
in the audience this is a live Q&A if
you have a question for Jason please
write it in the comment section and I'll
be sure to ask Jason okay all right
Jason other thing I want to ask you is
looking ahead what are the long term
effects and how serious could they be of
koban 19 yeah so we've heard about
people who have reported like a
reactivation of the infection they have
been sick with over 19 and then they've
felt better and feel like they've
recovered only two then days later
suddenly feel ill again
shortness of breath things like that now
doctors are concerned that that might
actually be because of blood clots that
are formed in the lung and that what
might be causing their shortness of
breath is the fact that blood is not
getting
around the lung like it should because
of these blood clots so it's a really
good sign or really good reminder to get
checked out the blood test to know
whether you have these blood clots
forming in your boat blood is a fairly
simple one and you can talk to your
doctor about whether that's appropriate
and then to get the right treatment if
it is indeed happening to you and the
cause of a reactivation feel like of
symptoms okay thank you Jason okay now
we're gonna go to the live audience we
have this question from I think it's kW
Kevin W Wilson why is this disease so
varied in its symptoms it's a good one
yeah I think it is a very good question
I think the answer is we don't really
know a lot of people have various
hypotheses around that genetics is
probably a really important element
although we haven't really figured out
yet what genetic differences are
predisposing people to having different
forms of it we know that symptoms can
vary depending on where the the
infection gets into our our cells the
medical or scientific term for that is
tropism so we know that the corona virus
has different tropisms so it can get
into your nose and start spreading there
in the cells in there epithelial cells
lining your upper Airways and that may
be what is causing a disrupted sense of
smell so that that's one issue we know
that if the virus does manage to get
down lower into the lungs where it can
damage those alveoli the grape-like air
sacs then that can certainly speed up a
process known as acute respiratory
distress syndrome or a RDS and that's a
more lethal complication of the corona
virus infection okay thank you another
question we have from I think this is
our YouTube viewer can you actually
recover from all of these symptoms the
answer is
yes which is great it probably depends
on the severity of your illness we know
that if you do have what I just
mentioned acute respiratory distress
syndrome that involves a lot of
inflammatory immune cells going into
your lung where your immune system
essentially goes a bit overboard and
trying to get rid of the virus and in
that that aberrant response can actually
do more damage to the lung tissue and it
can cause fibroid fry broddick material
to form in the lungs and scarring of the
lungs and unfortunately if that does
happen
that's going to be with you for awhile
if not forever so there it is possible
that it can cause some severe damage
that you may not recover from at least
immediately but overall most people
don't get severely sick it's only a
minority who do and overall you know
things like the loss of sense a smell
that does for most people return fairly
rapidly after the infection is cleared
and again like we've been finding
different symptoms as time goes on
doctors have been seeing more and more
difference in John's same with co19 we
don't know everything there is to know
about this particular condition disease
so you're saying that yes we can recover
from certain ones others we may have
other long-term effects yeah it's it's
really interesting obviously we've only
known about this disease for like four
months
but we are starting to see some patents
for example doctors in the Netherlands
reported that when there were when
patients experience severe
gastrointestinal upset that that is
associated with more severe disease so
we're starting to get a better picture
as to your water some of the patterns of
disease that might indicate that someone
is in for a worse or a milder course of
infection all right let's take some more
questions from our audience I have heard
this question from a few people before
so let me bring this
and is the other symptoms related to
your blood type do a certain blood type
you know are you more prone to
angstron symptoms and having those yeah
I have read some papers on that at least
one paper I think that came out from
China I think if I remember correctly
they were suggesting that the type A
blood blood group is more likely to
suffer worse symptoms then I think blood
group B from memory or blood group O
anyway I don't really quite remember
exactly all of the details but I'm
pretty sure that it is going to require
more investigation to properly
understand whether that is the thing if
it's a you know if it's a robust way of
understanding more about this disease I
think it's a little contested at the
moment okay all right next question
thank you guys for sending these in
super helpful does coronavirus kill kids
does it affect children and Jason knew
this before we heard in the beginning
you know a lot largely the elderly
population was at risk but now we're
learning a bit more recent yeah so we
know that overall age is one of the
biggest risk factors for getting sicker
from covert 19 and for a long time we
understood that children rarely get
infected and even will actually
infections among children occurred less
frequently than among adults and that
certainly children seem to be very
underrepresented among hospitalized
patients but that doesn't mean that
their risk is zero and now we're
actually seeing an Associated
inflammatory disease that appears a
little bit like a thing called Kawasaki
disease which is essentially
inflammation of the blood vessels and so
we're seeing children in Europe and in
North America who have been very sick
and needed intensive care for that for
this inflammatory blood vessel problem
which appears quite a lot like how is
our key disease they're still trying to
figure out if it is regardless it does
respond to
same treatment that is used for Kawasaki
disease its intravenous immunoglobulin
and when kids get that they do have a
really good chance of full recovery but
unfortunately this inflammatory blood
vessel problem has has been known to
kill children and it is a really severe
and but rare response to what we think
might be a response took over nineteen
it's still yet to be teased out the
majority of children who have had these
these worrying life-threatening symptoms
have either tested positive to the
coronavirus virus or to had antibodies
that suggest they've been exposed but
it's still yet to be completely
understood okay and we've been talking a
lot about blood clots in this particular
live stream so here's this next here's
this next question can we take aspirin
regularly to tackle clogging issues is
it part of preventing it yeah good
question I had the same question and I
asked the doctor that and he said no it
doesn't quite work that way aspirin is
the wrong kind of medication to take for
thinning the blood that works for
preventing certain more like the strokes
that typically people get but not for
the same kind of clotting problem we see
with Kovan 19 so aspirin unfortunately
isn't gonna work for this that's the
advice that I've been giving okay um you
know I want to keep going on and on
we're getting a lot more questions but
this one is gonna be the last one for
this live stream does kovin 19 test is
it detective iris immediately after it
you test positive does it take some time
I'm sorry immediately after a
contraction or does it take some time so
it depends on the test there is one
called a PCR test and that's looking for
the nucleic acid the genetic fingerprint
if you like the RNA that the virus has
particular features of the genetic
makeup
it's what the PCR test is looking for
and so if it finds the genetic signature
of of the corona virus it means that you
are infected you have the virus we also
know that the tests can find dead virus
so if it is picking up dead virus
particles those are not infectious and
if you tested positive for the corona
virus we don't know if you are
infectious because you have live virus
particles or whether these are in fact
dead virus particles that are being
found on you we know that there are a
lot of testing which is based on
antibodies that indicates whether you
have been exposed to the virus and
whether your immune system has mounted
an antibody response so that's what that
is testing and that tends to be positive
if you've been exposed and if you have
mounted an immune response about a week
or two after that exposure all right
well that wraps things up for us thanks
Jason so much our Bloomberg News health
editor for you giving us some great
answers as always hope to have you back
and thank you guys everybody for
watching make sure to follow us us at
quick-take for all the latest updates
and more bye for now thanks for me bye I